yeah there is no feeling like that first
little smile Chrissy Teigen sits down
with ETS Jennifer perros just one month
after the birth of her daughter Luna and
her first Mother's Day the entire day my
eyes were just like on the verge of
tears I was so happy it was so worth
like uncrossed a little bit and she's
like now rather than looking right
through you she like looks at you which
is really nice but it's like the little
smiles that gets you and here's what
surprised the new mama the most you're
you're kind of breastfeeding for like
ten hours a day totally they just use
you for your milk and you just feel like
you are just a cow all day like it's
hard to work your entire day around you
know getting her all the nourishment she
needs cuz they're just there are little
animals there just want [ __ ] you guys
heard her she took one look at me
instead of being like oh good mom's here
she was like ya know my mom one thing
you're good for one day right yes life
is definitely different now but Chrissy
jumped right back into her passion of
cooking partnering with Lowrey season
salt though this foodie admits her
priorities have shifted food just
doesn't cross your mind it's like
whereas before it was number one on my
list now you know Lunas up there Luna
and John and and but keeping the dogs
happy speaking of John surprisingly
fatherhood hasn't changed him much he's
always been so calm and like you know
very collected and very uh I feel like I
have calmed down a lot more John has
really remained the same though like he
just dances around with or he sings to
her of course and but yeah he's a it's
nice seeing him like just so attached to
something and
you